right I'm on camera before I go to the
glass tonight that means only one thing
they have a trailer I probably want to
talk about in this case the spider-man
far from home that's right it's the
first trailer - spider-man far from home
- takes place after Avengers end game a
lot of people are like this is a spoiler
did you really not think come on did you
not know spider-man would be coming back
along with Black Panther yeah they would
never bring a Black Panther back I will
say in this trailer it is interesting
that Tony Stark's is nowhere to be found
he's just not in here we have happy we
have Nick Fury Nick Fury's doing the
James Bond sitting in the shadows he has
a suit when you didn't pack his suit and
you knew the trailer it shows that Peter
Parker looks all sad and close to the
doors I know my suit maybe because it
reminds me of Tony Stark and he's dead
because of endgame we don't know but in
the international trailer it shows Aunt
May left a note it's like oh you forgot
this spider-man suit it's also a funny
moment in the trailer but Aunt May
there's someone gotta call CPS on you
are you advocating that your teenage
nephew has his suit to run into trouble
for you like hey in case you want to run
headfirst into trouble here you go you
might die whatever you spider-man that's
awesome I'm just saying most Guardian
figures would be like don't be
spider-man maybe they had that moment we
won't say it on screen maybe they'll
have that moment in the beginning of
this movie the big thing to talk about
for me is Hydra man that's Hydra man and
I guess Hydra man can be rock man or
that's Hydra man and that Sandman's all
night for - I don't know why I draw the
line there we've seen Infinity stones
we've seen them snap people out of
existence we've seen gods who are aliens
it's science and magic learning the same
we've actually seen magic but hydro-man
that feels weird here but I do love
seeing Mysterio full suit fighting Hydra
man and I know it's a thing to do on
YouTube to theorize what's happening
what do I see what do I think is gonna
happen in the movie that's kind of
absurd because it's just one trailer but
here's totally what I think might be
happening if I came to theorize what
Mysterio comes down he's like you don't
want any part of this and he fights
hydro man hydro man who was apparently a
dude whose water still kind of feels out
of place in this universe what if and
I'm saying what if but Mysterio deals in
special effects I know a lot of people
like oh he knows magic maybe he learned
from dr. strangers cults but Mysterio
while he has delved into magic because
you know to up his game red there's one
story where he was in jail and he'd
summon this thing as demons blow out the
side of the prison and the demons cured
vultures cancer is a thing but really
Mysterio deals in visual effects and
special effects
what if Hydra Man is just Mysterio tech
I can see Hydra man being Mysterio tech
threat the Mysterio's created so
Mysterio can come in take out that
threat that he created so he can be the
hero of the day it's like he wants to be
seen as a hero without putting any of
the work into being a hero although
because he realized being a hero is very
monetizable cuz what's the consensus of
Mysterio after he fights hydro-man here
who is that guy he's like Iron Man Thor
role didn't want to be received by the
people in that light I can see Mysterio
creating a fake threat to fight the fake
threat so he could be seen as a hero
which seemed way cooler just now before
I realized syndrome did that exact same
thing in The Incredibles hmm do you
think Disney's gonna sue Disney if it's
real another interesting thing this is
fourth wall breaking interesting this
trailer isn't on the Marvel YouTube
channel it's on the Sony one spider-man
homecoming was on the Marvel one that's
where it was that part of the contract
they were like all right you can use
spider-man as long as we get the
spider-man trailers for the second movie
all right let's get this ain't dry I do
like the end of this trailer that was
pretty funny what is it with you and
spider-man what he looks out for the
neighbor it has a dope suit and I really
respect him sup dickwad it has always
been a great ironic thing that Flash
Thompson does not like Peter Parker but
loves spider-man and that pretty much
hit at home first so those are my
thoughts on the spider-man far from home
trailer and my thoughts on what might be
happening with Mysterio and hydro-man
whether or not it's actually a legit
conflict or whether Mysterio is actually
syndrome from The Incredibles but in
terms of the trailer what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]